bonjour à tous ici votre art go rock
nationale avant que la vidéo commence je
me dois de vous dire certaines choses
tout d'abord je serai présent aux
guildes ace de rennes le 2 et 3 mars
je suis invité à faire des dédicaces de
11 heures à midi et toute façon j'y
serai toute la journée
argo rock en dédicace mdr la grosse tête
quoi j'ai également deux passes une
journée à vous faire gagner donc si vous
souhaitez gagner une place je vous
invite à participer en rejoignant
twitter cas dans la description et je
tirerai les gagnants le jeudi 28 mars
il y aura donc deux gagnants je suis
très heureux de participer à cet
événement ça va être vraiment une grosse
expérience pour ma part et j'espère
quand même voir certains d'entre vous
enfin et je vous lâche la théorie du
siècle après j'aimerais revenir sur
quelques petits points concernant mes
vidéos sur marvel j'ai fait vraiment
beaucoup de théories sur le mc eu et
évidemment je ne peux pas traiter
l'intégralité de ce qu'il y aura dans
venture 4 dans une seule vidéo fait donc
ne soyez pas étonnés si des fois dans
une vidéo je ne parle pas de tony stark
ou de docteur strange malgré qu'ils
soient hyper important par vidéo je ne
m'intéresse qu'à des points précis qu'il
y aura dans le film
donc voilà en fait je vous invite à voir
l'entièreté des vidéos que j'ai fait sur
le mc ou si vous voulez avoir une vision
globale fin ma vision globale de ce
qu'il y aura dans le film ceci étant dit
n'oubliez jamais que ce ne sont que des
théories évidemment donc je vous invite
à laisser un petit pouce bleus et
activer la cloche
allez maintenant je vous laisse avec la
vidéo
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
on parle de voyage dans le temps depuis
un bon moment mais on ne s'intéresse
qu'à ses bons côtés
techniquement je vous dis toujours que
ventures 4 aura de lourdes conséquences
que le film ne sera pas rose mais
pourtant nous n'en parlons pas il est
temps d'y remédier avec une vidéo bien
sombre sur les conséquences du voyage
dans le temps et d'avengers 4
premièrement j'aimerais que nous nous
rappelions du personnage de mort d'eau
dans le premier film de l'origine story
du docteur strange car bordeaux évolue
énormément au cours du film ce dernier
s'est senti trahi par l'ancien qui
tirait ses pouvoirs et son immortalité
de la dimension noir ainsi que de son
ancien compagnon stéphane strange devenu
le sorcier suprême qui a appris à
manipuler le temps via l'oeil d'agde à
moto
bordeaux s'est senti trahi car il est
certainement le sorcier le plus fidèle
concernant les principes des arts
mystiques
il clame haut et fort qu certaines
règles de la nature ne doivent pas être
enfreintes
prenons l'exemple du moment où il a
appris que strange manipuler le temps
vialèlle d'agde à moto je cite tu veux
rester coincé à revivre le même moment
encore et encore
ou ne jamais avoir existé il est clair
que le monde du marvel cinématiques
universe eux n'y va pas de main morte
concernant les super pouvoirs et va
toujours de plus en plus loin mais s'il
ya bien une chose à respecter c'est les
lois naturelles de l'univers ne pas
aller à l'encontre de l'avis de la mort
ou encore du temps qui passe
je ne vous cache pas que depuis un
moment je pense que strange devra subir
des conséquences de ses actes
mais j'ai changé d'avis si nous
reprenons les phrases de mort dont nous
pourrions avoir une certaine métaphore
strange a inversé la menace que lui
avait expliqué mme hors d'eau en
enfermant dormammu dans une boucle
temporelle
c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment qu'il est
devenu très puissant à force de
combattre encore et encore dormammu cela
explique sa force dans une finition
noire
je vous l'avais d'ailleurs expliqué dans
mon trois théories sur doctor strange
bref parenthèse fermée si nous nous
intéressons à l'autre menace de mort dos
concernant la manipulation du temps il
lui dit qu'il pourrait ne jamais avoir
existé
c'est une conséquence que strange a subi
dans infinity ward thanos est le symbole
en quelque sorte des lois de la nature
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
il cherche les pierre d'infini pour
restaurer l'équilibré naturel de la vie
strange suite au claquement de doigt par
donc en fumée comme s'il n'avait jamais
existé dans le mc eu
nous pouvons donc y faire une sorte de
rapprochement néanmoins cette vision est
à double tranchant car thanos accuse
strange de posséder un pouvoir dont ils
ne se servent pas et c'est également une
possible conséquence de sa chute
ma vision a totalement changé par
rapport à la manipulation du temps comme
l'expriment bordeaux stéphane strange
depuis qu'il est devenu un sorcier et
par la suite sorcier suprême passe le
plus clair de son temps à protéger et
étudier l'oeil d'agde à moto au point
qu'il a vu via ce dernier plus de 14
millions de futurs différents pour
vaincre le titan strange ne subira pas
les conséquences du temps car il est
quelqu'un de sage et d'expérimenter il
s'est permis d'effectuer une boucle
temporelle face à dormammu car le temps
n'a quasiment aucun impact dans la
dimension noir et face à cassis luce
hong kong était déjà à moitié dans la
dimension noir et quand bien même sens à
la ville seraient détruites
bref si strange manipule le temps c'est
que c'est nécessaire et que c'est un
recours ultime
nous pouvons lui faire confiance
malheureusement très jeune et pas ultime
et san en puissance face aux actes de
thanos l'obligent à se laisser partir
pour déléguer à tony stark le sort du
futur ainsi qu'évidemment les autres
avengers
ceci le fera très certainement réfléchir
quant à son impact en tant que sorcier
suprême et protecteur de la pierre du
temps strange a failli en quelque sorte
à sa mission
néanmoins d'autres conséquences plus
lourdes peuvent arriver si je vous
raconte tout ceci depuis le début ce
n'est pas pour rien dans le mc eu
seulement deux personnages ont manipulé
le temps strange et thanos thanos
possède une grande connaissance des
pierres et c'est utiliser la pierre du
temps avec précision seuls des
personnages plutôt qualifiés ont
manipulé véritablement le temps dans le
mc eu si nous restons dans le discours
de mort d'eau nous savons que thanos
perdra à la fin d'un ventures 4 d'une
quelconque manière sa défaite pourrait
être une conséquence de sa manipulation
des lois naturelles mais bref c'est
qu'une idée très philosophique
néanmoins comme vous le savez je suppose
à 200% que les avengers restants vont
devoir manipuler le temps pour ramener
les héros et les gens disparus
effectivement non pas par la pierre mais
normalement par la dimension quantique
nous pourrions penser que c'est quelque
chose de différent vu que ça ne concerne
pas forcément la pierre mais détrompez
vous cela concerne bien le voyage dans
le temps le concept des conséquences du
voyage dans le temps est vieux comme
l'ancien réfléchi saisi deux minutes
et rappelez-vous par exemple de retour
vers le futur où le présent et modifier
due aux erreurs de marty dans le passé
ou encore harry potter et le prisonnier
d'azkaban où harry et hermione ne
doivent en aucun cas croiser quelqu'un
pour éviter un paradoxe temporel les
paradoxes temporels tiens c'est aussi
les risques d'un film de la saga marvel
x men days of future past
comme quoi même si nous ne sommes pas
dans le mc eu marvel utilisent déjà ce
procédé
nos chers aux avengers n'ont aucune
expérience concernant le voyage dans le
temps et vont devoir pourtant le
manipuler je me demande même si à part
au rwanda quelqu'un s'est rendu compte
que thanos avait remonté le temps pour
ressusciter vision ce lanthemann
possédera une courte expérience via le
vortex temporel et encore ce ne sera pas
suffisant
il est clair et net que de possibles
paradoxe ou des erreurs vont être
commises dans le passé erreurs qui
pourraient altérer le présent menant à
une victoire contre thanos mais avec
certainement des disparitions de
certains personnages ou héros je ne
pense pas que marvel s'attarderait trop
là dessus mais imaginez un présent ou la
victoire face à tan hausse serait totale
mais où ultre on aurait gagné ou l'eau
qui aurait gagné ou dormammu aurait
gagné la défaite sera bel et bien là
comme quoi cela peut rassurer certains
sur le fait que nos avengers ne vont pas
pouvoir s'amuser à balayer la saga du mc
eu mais seulement semer quelques graines
mais des héros ou autre personnage
important périront et devront laisser
leur place pour un futur meilleur
nick fury est un bon exemple samuel
jackson a aujourd'hui 70 ans et son
personnage pourrait être remplacé par
tony stark dirigeants le shield après
avoir emballé son armure d'iron man nous
sommes à la fin de la phase iii et
prochainement le début de la phase 4
emc eu avance et évoluent les
personnages vont devoir suivre ou périr
d'ailleurs suite à l'introduction du
personnage de captain marvel les deux
piliers principaux de nick fury seront
enfin réunies pour protéger ensemble la
planète
c'est en partie pour ça que captain
marvel n'est jamais apparu avant car
tony n'est jamais tombé au combat
contrairement à ce que pense nick fury à
la fin d'une infiniti war cela explique
la raison de son appel nick fury
n'aurait plus son utilité et pourraient
partir en paix en quelque sorte
bien qu'elle soit éphémère néanmoins je
suis assez mauvaises langues nous ne
connaissons encore très peu de choses
concernant le personnage de captain
marvel mais elle est élue comme la plus
puissante des avengers
il est apparemment dit qu'elle tirerait
ses pouvoirs du chant quantique peut
être connaît-elle quelque peu les
conséquences du voyage dans le temps de
plus c'est dans ces moments que strange
pourrait refaire son apparition il est
dit d'après certains lic qu'il
communiquerait avec wang en tant que
corps astral ce dernier pourrait
retrouver les avengers dans le champ
quantique pour les guider et leur
expliquer les conséquences de leurs
actes cela mettrait en lumière le fait
qu'il avait effectivement tout prévu
dans infinity voir
après tout l'ancien l'avait fait voyager
à travers la dimension quantique lors du
film sur son origin story nous pourrions
voir suite à un game comment mordoré
agirait face aux précédentes actions du
docteur et s'ils dorment amour aurait
profité des manipulations du temps pour
se venger de ce train
jh c'est tout de même son ennemi ultime
mais c'est un autre sujet que nous
pourrons sa portée
je suis peut-être pas très optimiste
mais il fallait mettre en évidence les
conséquences d'un sujet dont nous
traitons quand même assez souvent
j'espère que vous aurez réussi à suivre
ma pensée et que je ne vous aurais pas
perdu en chemin j'ai vraiment hâte de
voir avengers 4 et d'enfin avoir des
réponses
je vous invite à activer la cloche pour
ne louper aucune de mes prochaines
vidéos et à me mettre un gros pouce
bleus qui soutient énormément ont
travaillé et m'aide beaucoup
enfin bref c'était targo rock et que le
liner soit avec vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]